what do you remember about that time in
your life
barely anything if i'm being honest um
it was a whirlwind
i was probably on the road for 275 days
out of 365.
it was such a taxing
experience of shows radio tour red eyes
i never slept
um i was i stayed kind of sick because
of that you know singing through strep
throat multiple times
you know i definitely had these joyous
moments but everything was moving
so fast and i was so exhausted that i
didn't have much time
to take it in
a girl
early on you're just saying yes to
everything and then you realize that
you're just completely
your tank is completely empty but yet it
keeps
it's go go go you know and that mindset
is reflected
on the deluxe version of kip's album
wild world which features his new song
how high girl
[Applause]
what was your reaction the first time
you saw the video by the end of it i was
moved to tears pretty much like
i found it so powerful
because i think about my own grandmother
that just passed and you know she lost
my grandfather she lost him back in 2011
and so she's been living these last you
know eight nine years without her
partner of you know 50 some odd years
i can't imagine the fragile state once
you get to that age and you watched
everybody pass around you
you're still left you know and just that
so
yeah i just thought it was a very unique
emotional spin on the whole song